hey guys I'm Ryan right so today I'm
gonna be checking out the trailer for
the gallows I saw the teaser trailer
that looked good I hope this one looks
good too alright stage let's do what we
came here for
oh you sir this is a smart idea
hello
senior charlie grimille died after a
crop malfunction during the high
school's presentation of the gallows Oh
someone's died in school
what happened it's Charlie
he's real is out of here totally jumpy
don't say his name Charlie Charlie - you
shouldn't say that name
[Music]
we have both borrow someone will come
[Music]
yes horror movies man
I like them I love them sometimes but
man I always regret it when I'm watching
it I mean for one the character still
seemed like idiots out of a horror movie
you don't go to a scary place and then
start [ __ ] it up I mean that's just
stupid idiots the white white kids are
dumb so the situation the setup of how
it goes into all this yeah that's a
little dumb to me there are some
positives I like the fact that it takes
place at a school schools are creepy at
night especially when the gym teacher
still their [ __ ] coach Rios may you
scare the [ __ ] out of me dude I like
horror flicks that take place at school
schools are creepy there's a whole
history there there's old people that
used to work there their lives were
committed to their children no one died
there yeah it's scary creepy I mean the
cinematography looks good too I love the
way everything looks I mean yeah it's
like found footage style but there
actually looks like there's more style
than just found footage and the
cinematography especially how they're
messing with the red lighting that
looked really good
and I don't know what rating this movie
is they might have said it at the
beginning before the trailer but it
doesn't look like it's gonna rely
heavily on violence which I really like
like violence should be used at in the
right kind of horror movie for this and
I feel like if there's gonna be like
gory violence it should only be a few
moments I mean like how often do we see
horror movie trailers now where there's
like quotes from critics saying how
terrifying it is and normally the film
ends up not being so terrifying like
those critics tend to go into the film
but without watching a trailer yet
especially for these kind of lower
budget horror flicks as opposed to us
who get these trailers and then we go in
with preconceived notions and images so
it makes it not as scary but if this
happens to live up to the hype of those
quotes that would be really [ __ ] cool
because right now this Phil
looks like a fun good time but it
doesn't look like it's anything that
original but as long as it gets a few
scares hopefully not too many jump
scares with legitimate scare since
there's a few silly jump scares in this
trailer but if it gets the scare factor
done if it's entertaining sure then I'm
on board for it horror is a hard John
root to get down right so if you like
happen to get past like the 50% mark on
Rotten Tomatoes I'm like that's still
pretty good even like a 39% good for a
horror flick anyway guys thanks for
telling me that was out if you needed
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram or Twitter where if
we get enough followers we can give
product placement for things such as
pillows pillows are great they relax
your head your back and both of those
relax while you're getting head ah did
forget a head on the bed yeah head in
the car I mean if you have a pillow with
you I'm sure it's a better experience
but it's really just distracting it
increases the odds of you getting in a
car crash significantly almost as high
as you know being a drunk driver on the
road so my guys are really into it but
wrote it to me seems scary you're more
likely to get teeth on your penis but
all that goes away with pillows